I think what I would like people to know
about performing as a drag artist is
that you don't have to be a Type A or a
Type B the whole point of draggin that
there isn't rules drag was really how I
found myself as a person I feel like
drag is dusk I have been performing for
four years
my pronouns are they them I am Titus
androgynous prefer see him they them
I've been leaning more toward sadly them
and I've been performing for seven or
eight years my name is Bob Sinclar I go
by a them or sometimes he hammer onstage
as well and I've been performing for
four years I'm Clint Eastwood I've been
doing drag for about three years and I
go by a more than I'm out of drag but in
drag I've been preferring more he well
in drag I am or identify as just like a
man it was too much gender for his shoes
I mean for me personally drag is like
and everything that I have wanted to
ever be is like acceptable like it is my
escape into doing something that like
wouldn't normally be possible I can be
any character I want to I don't know
drag it's kind of like being a superhero
like drag is in half affirming and my
gender identity because like I've done
this in order to like push my boundaries
of my gender expression but at the same
time I've discovered more about myself
that won't like along the way drag is
being your true self because we are
ever-changing and that honestly is what
inspires my drag is just to be what the
effort it's whatever you want it to be
male female somewhere in between it's
sort of exploring the spectrum of gender
the whole point of drag is to show like
the ridiculousness of like the
expectations put on men and women and
how we're supposed to present them how
we're supposed to form but in recent
years I've kind of in real I think just
like with my gender identity
my transition like the more I started to
take hormones the more comfortable I got
about the ideas of like not having to
ascribe to like male or female but you
can fit in the in-between and I feel
like drag had become extremely binary in
the last few years sometimes even in
your own community that you get a lot of
folks who still don't understand what
your expression is you know and they put
you you know under that category what
they view you as and what they perceive
you as I think I I fighted the most by
being visible like just what what has
kept me going is just and what is
literally just lit a fire under my ass
it's just like a fact to be visible when
I first started drag I was traditional
drag more feminine for a long time I was
going through just this battling if I
was trans or not I kind of was able to
play around with the the rules of gender
it did kind of like open my eyes to like
what my true essence was I generally
consider myself a drag king or somewhere
like in the middle like a drag thing
drag was really how I found myself as a
person I guess when I started drag I had
always felt like sort of like a
masculine energy inside and that kind of
allowed me to bring that out like I went
sort of full mask was considering like
transitioning and I was like I'm like
I'm a trans man and this is like my
identity as I sort of progressed through
drag and I learned more and I did
research on other performers I was like
I kind of feel like I still fall in the
middle and I sort of gotten to a place
because of drag where I can accept my
body for what it is and and just allow
it to be that I've both gender and it
pays me
I don't feel like a he still even in
this like that's the whole point of why
I picked the name is that it's more of
like kind of a really gay alien Titus is
where I can hide and like put on
clothing that I'm afraid to wear on
public I feel more like myself in this
persona than I do in everyday life
there's been many times where I've felt
both empowered and also like it felt
like my powers take it away from me at
the same time you know it's just like
also when you get this platform to
perform its euphoric you know like first
time I put on a mug it was euphoric you
know I'm just like oh this is like what
I really wish I could be you know just
something that transcends humanity my
art is inspired from my hardships in my
life I was young I was in foster care
for a long while and through moving
around a lot through foster care and
moving around a lot with my father who
was in the military a lot of ridicule
for being queer a lot of ridicule for
being darker than most people so I took
that and I turned it into something
something that's shaped this that can be
understood by everyone and some kind of
way regardless if it was male or female
I just wanted to be the shapeless figure
that someone could look at I just wanted
to take my hardships or take the
ridicule I've been through
find a little bit of light in it Kings
are just as valid and the people who are
in between are really pushing for this
different idea of gender because like
that's where it starts I think it's
really important to our culture now to
have that as a form of self-expression
especially in the queer community to be
able to explore your gender and explore
your sexuality and just explore like
what it is that you're passionate about
then you can take that and you can put
it on stage non-binary drag exists there
are aliens among us and I think like you
know we need to be seen people
appreciate what we do and the only way
to like start being like oh you know
people don't want to see weird stuff
that's cuz you don't book it no the only
reason why it's because you don't book
it and people aren't used to seeing it I
don't know I just want people to stop
boxing us in I just pray for more
openness more acceptance it's more love
that's what we're missing I know it's
really cheesy but it oddly comes down to
love to be honest
[Music]
you
[Music]